Android studio 3.4 is now available for
download on the stable channel along
with version 3.4 of the android plug-in
for Gradle this version of Android
studio fixes a number of issue and add
few new features a resource manager new
capabilities to the project structure
dialog and enables our eight our new
katrinka by default this release is an
incremental quality release as part of
project marble and it's specifically
light on new features in order to fix
primarily on bug fixes and quality see
tuned for even more on project marble
updates in the 3.5 release the resource
major is a new tool that helps you
manage your application drawable colors
and layouts you can bulk import resource
files in your project convert SVG's into
vector drawables visualize your resource
without having to open them and even
drag and drop draw balls from the
resource manager unto the layout editor
coinciding with the navigation library
stable release the navigation editor in
Android studio now supports all type of
arguments which mean no need to manually
edit your navigation file for previously
in supported types the project structure
dialog has been redesigned and includes
many new improvements to help you
configure project properties without
manually editing your build.gradle files
it includes rich UI support for working
with module variables you can explore
the dependency graph of your project
with a new resolve dependencies view and
use the suggestion page to manage
dependency conflicts and update if you
start using jetpack and firebase classes
in your code we added a new intention
action that suggests adding the required
Gradle library dependency to your
project if you haven't already done so
on the build side we have now made our
aid the default code optimizer for
Android builds replacing ProGuard
previously separated tools were used to
handle different stages of compilation
the sugaring of Java class files
texing' cut shrinking and optimizations
making the build process longer enry
studio 3.1 introduced d8 a new codec sir
that takes on the sugaring and
transforming class files into dalvik
bytecode with Android grade
plug in 3.4 and higher we're replacing
of the last part cut shrinking an
optimization with our 8 a single tool
that combines the functionality of d8
and ProGuard resulting in noticeable
build performance improvements keep in
mind our 8 is designed to work with your
existing product rules so you shouldn't
need to make any changes to start using
our 8
we tested against the Santa tracker
project at the shrinking plus texting
time was nearly 50% faster than using
pro god ra 8 supports Android library
projects as well
if you experience issues using our 8
when building a ARS please report a bug
on our tracker you can also disable our
8 for only your Android library projects
with this code in your Gradle file by
default our 8 works as a drop-in
replacement for ProGuard by running in a
compatibility mode there is also a full
mode available which enables more
optimization but the compatibility with
ProGuard is no longer assured you can
enable the full map by adding this line
to a Gradle property file if you're
still using the command rate feature
plug-in to build your instant app
Android Gradle plug-in 3.4 will show you
a deprecation warning to make sure you
can still build your instant app on
future versions of the plug-in migrate
to instant app to the dynamic feature
plug-in doing so allows you to build and
publish a single instant enabled Android
app bundle for both the instant and
installed versions of your app when
building native libraries NDK compile is
now duplicated and it will produce a
build error if you try to use it you
should instead use either C make or NDK
build to add C and C++ code to your
project enjoy Android studio 3.4 and
remember that we are listening to your
feedback on our bug tracker you can test
early build of Android studio 3.5 on the
canary channel see you soon
[Music]